welcome to the program genomic data
analysis so whether you are just
starting your journey or looking to
expand your expertise this program is
designed to provide you with the skills
and the knowledge that is needed to
excel in this rapidly evolving field
at the beginner level you will develop a
strong Foundation exploring
bioinformatics Next Generation
sequencing techniques you will gain the
ability to explore and analyze genomic
data through data exploration and
sequence alignment from advancements in
Next Generation sequencing Technologies
to understanding the entire workflow
from sequencing reads quality control
alignment and annotation which files are
involved what it includes how to prepare
them what are the steps of analysis what
parameters to use and finally how to
annotate the variants observed when
reads are aligned on the reference
genome the intermediate level takes you
deeper into intriguing topics such as
variant calling copy number variation
analysis machine learning genome bite
Association studies and ethical
concentrations for those seeking
Advanced knowledge we delve into
population genetics DNA sequence
analysis VCF file analysis functional
annotation and real-life case studies on
sarskov 2 breast cancer oncogene vacant
calling and Ebola
by joining this program you will gain
practical hands-on experience learn
cutting-edge techniques and unravel the
Mysteries hidden within genomic data be
prepared to unlock a world of exciting
possibilities and make significant
contributions in the field of genomic
data analysis
towards the end of the program you will
be able to work on your own research
project with your research question in
hand if you wish to join the research
fellowship program towards the end of
the program you will gain an expertise
to carry your own independent research
and work on a research question of your
interest under mental guidance
there are several exciting job roles in
the field of genomics and data science
as the field keeps growing more job
opportunities are opening up here are
some potential job roles you can
consider a bioinformatics analyst
position scientific database curator
clinical genomic analyst data scientist
research scientist and genetic counselor
to learn more about your dream
opportunities that you can hit with the
skill set that you gain from this
program you can scroll the program page
and go through the frequently asked
questions we'll meet in the program
thank you